all
right what's going on you just gonna sit
there and St at me like a like I'm on
Law and Order oh no I I thought I
thought you when you were ready we're
gonna play the intro all right play the
intro let's do it what's happening you
Savages Uncle Joey here the checkin is
brought to you by stamps.com they
already got Christmas stuff on the
shelves and things are about to get
crazy if you're a business owner or even
just a guy that's got packages to send
then you need stamps.com stamps.com is
your own personal post office wherever
you are all you need is a printer and a
computer listen I've been with them for
close to 10 years my wife still uses
them for little things here and there
why because you print your own Postage
and discounts up to 84% off you USPS and
UPS rates and stamps.com will even let
you know the cheapest and fastest
shipping options to help you save even
more money if you want to save time as
well as money you can even schedule
package pickups and through stamps.com
the dashboard it couldn't be any easier
if I could do it so can you so do
yourself a favor give your business the
gift of stamps.com so you're mailing and
shipping is covered this holiday season
sign up with promo code Joey for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale no long-term commitments to
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and press in code
Joey turn off your TVs run for your
lives it's over they didn't put you on
this planet just just to give up if
Uncle Joey could do it I could rule the
world that's what you got to be thinking
welcome back
[Music]
to what's happening my brother November
the 6 we're here it's a whole new month
with a whole new set of rules hold on
after the the phone rang I had to shut
my thing on airplane mode
and people going to start bothering me
any minute what's going on my little
brother I'm just happy to see you dude
it's crazy when you like it's
Thanksgiving pretty much all right
beautiful I got the little red suit on
today like a like one of those Christmas
dudes that helped Santa Claus I got the
new lighting I got the bookshelf up like
an animal I got the books in there the
albums I'm feeling good brother it's a
whole new week a whole new month you
should be looking at just the same oh
I'm excited why did you decide to redo
your office because it looked like
[__] debt I wanted to set it up my
computer my desk over there I got my
little podcast studio right here you
know Tick Tock Magoo no drama no nothing
I don't got to drive behind a dirty
building at night when I leave I'm
thinking I'm gonna get mugged somebody
sent me a picture where the old church
was which one the one next to the in-
and out or no the one where we ended it
okay what happened it looks like a bomb
hit that
place it looks like a bomb hit it like
uh the grass growing in the parking lot
somebody broke down the fence you know
well that was a weird office like they
were all very nice but that like he and
to got well remember when the lady stole
two of our
buns well to be fair we did leave them
in the we left them I think you walk in
the bathroom you see a bung you leave it
there you don't touch that stuff that's
like bumping into a dead chicken on a
corner in New York City you leave that
there you don't touch that stuff you
don't go to you don't call SVU and check
out the chicken you know what I'm saying
you just keep walking oh they got so mad
and they and it really it broke the
camels back at the first office when
they kept accusing us of smoking weed
and we were really good we never smoked
tweet in that office and then from that
office on we were like we're going to
smoke in every [__] office no we I
remember I went to one off with my wife
that was like a it looked like where
they put Adam s on The Longest Yard it
had like aluminum it must have been 115
[__] degrees when I walked in I go
what's the air L's like we keeping it 68
68 68 you better turn that down to
32 ding in here it was metal all the way
up in the valley no buildings around it
nothing the sun's beating on it all day
I'm n I'm not doing this then we had the
place in the Ghetto by the 7-Eleven on
the corner right that was the first one
and that's where we got thrown out where
the lady kept pounding on the door there
was an earthquake there my uncle did it
he got stuck you know
that Luke office how we kept it going
after that is beyond me it's beyond mean
because we were in that office we were
searching around but in the meantime I
was walking with the a crib one day and
I'm walking towards that little Park
where they used to shoot Sons of Anarchy
and all that [__] and I see a guy
standing
outside our podcast studio and I go up
to him hey man I did a podcast in there
years earlier it was gray Drake's
podcast so I knew they did a podcast in
that and I go I did a podc in there one
time is there any offices and he goes
no I said I'll leave my number he goes
all right 11 months later as we were
getting thrown out of the other
place he called us with that
place and
then the only podcasting to get thrown
out of multiple offices I don't know how
long we did the stint where you found
the guy in the alleyway sleeping up on
that guy was there for a while that was
there up on up by the in and out there
was just a homeless dude I think about
that guy a lot he was so smart he broke
in and he just laid there he laid
against the wall he didn't say anything
he didn't do and everyone was just like
embarrassed or like I'm like Doug man
your business you don't know nothing and
someone didn't mind their business they
went to the bathroom with the door
unlocked and he stole her
purse like he just got up R stole a
person
left that's the office where we had
Steven bow with the dog and his
girlfriend knocked in the door right no
the I I thought step Bower came to the
last one because he lived close to no no
no no the first time Steph bow came on
oh he knocked on the door that time
you're right okay yes and then that's
where we had the
pimp first
time both times he's dead as disco oh
yeah all right that poor kisser de you
know it's it's really [__] hysterical
about the office situations we had now
you know I got a little cubicle in my
[__] back room here I gotta wear a
sweatshirt because it's freezing but I
love
it do oh my God Al what you you just
spend all day in there huh I said you
just spend all day in there now I wake
up in the morning I get a cup of coffee
I go outside I'll do a little gratitude
I relax if it's real cold I stay outside
I take some [__] and then I come down
here my coffee is finished I go on the
internet I read whatever is pertains to
me and I either put something up or you
know it's not like the old days where I
used to have to think of stuff five days
a week that ship sales you know what I'm
saying two days you get from me you know
and uh I answer some emails and you know
I got to follow up with people you know
constantly so that's part of it Friday
we find out whether we're nominated for
Grammy or not [__] yeah so you know you
call people and they're like how you
doing what do you mean how we doing have
you checked have you called the [__]
grandma n I've been busy [__] playing
the Bongos okay what do you want from me
huh yeah no no out there it's a
different world out there tan but you
know what man my weekend was easy nice I
had a b
dog this is how how different my life is
I thought the UFC in New York City was
last
Saturday so
I there was a UFC that's why when Jon
Jones cancelled I kept hearing about dck
Lewis fighting some guy and I'm like ah
maybe they replac him you know I don't
[__] follow up on this [__] no more I
don't know nothing I knew Jon Jones was
gonna that's it I was so excited for Jon
Jones I was playing Soul music I was
watch fly the whole [__] thing I was
Jon Jones the return you know and I
don't know I was excited to see Stipe
too it's been a while since saw that
Savage whatever the outcome I was just
excited to maybe go over there it would
have been a long night for Uncle Joy I
would have had to get a room in the
city oh yeah [__] had like somebody
pick me the [__] up right as I would
have to run up to the top of the garden
watch the screen and get out of there so
all week long I'm like you know what I
got this I got a party to go to early a
50th party to go to early on
Saturday and I'll hang at the party at
one point you know us we Abandoned Ship
how you doing vote for me you give a
couple people a joint you give somebody
a hug where you going I gotta go to the
bathroom boom I'm on my way to the city
I get up to the ferry maybe take an Uber
over take another Uber the [__] not an
Uber over to the city take the ferry and
take an Uber to the
guard that's a plan that was the plan
get there about
9:30 you know the place will be packed I
was gonna Joe was GNA hook me up
somewhere so I was all excited I hadn't
seen Joe since
Austin so that was the [__] plan till
Friday Friday the party I was going to
one of my friends
called and I go I'll see you at the
party tomorrow night he's like what are
you talking about I go that party's
tomorrow night and he goes what are you
talking about I go yeah 7:30 I just
spoke to them he goes no it's next
[__]
Saturday I go what are you talking
about so I go I had to call somebody and
double check but then Friday I didn't
hear from Joe so did it made sense so
it's in a week what happened it's in a
week yeah this weekend got it okay back
the [__] countdown was last night and
again I got caught watching some [__]
show from the creator of uh
Yellowstone about a black slave that
breaks away and shoots a bunch of white
people I love it you know tremendous
black
power6 is that the name of the show no I
don't know what the name of the show is
but it doesn't really matter it's a good
show it's on
yeah that's fun I had a good week I saw
Bill bur last
night or Sunday night what you said to
me today if you don't want to repeat it
on the podcast I'll repeat anything you
don't have to but it's very interesting
when you said that to
me and tell the people what you told me
about the lighting your opinion here oh
my opinion so I got really lucky in the
past month I saw Jerry Seinfeld Dave
Chappel twice and Bill Bur
and they were all great in different
ways but the best one like by far the
most fun we had was at
bber which was sein very Seinfeld's very
polite on stage he wears the suit he
gives you a different vibe but it ain't
[__] fun he makes you laugh but you
know what I'm saying like I get it I get
it Dave Chappelle on the other hand he's
excited fighting you know I always
thought that but I gotta be honest with
you i' I've been a big b a bill bur fan
like I told you I had a conversation
with him he disappeared then I saw him
on the Chappelle show and I was cheering
for him I didn't know and then all of a
sudden you know he's getting booed in
Philadelphia and you know now and he's
solid I love everything about him I
watched that movie the first afternoon
it came out then I watched the again the
next day and I enjoyed it and I
respected the [__] the critics went
against it and he got 29 million [__]
views so everybody had to shut their
mouth at the end of the week you know
what I'm saying it was entertainment
nobody had to take it personal here and
you know everybody takes everything so
[__] personal
today I've heard that's good I haven't I
haven't got to see the movie but he all
I could think of like when I was
thinking about what
I got from his set like other than then
it was like funny was like he I think
he pretty much better than anyone like
actually like seems like himself during
this like there's no real different I
I've never met him personally so I don't
know but between his podcast and standup
who he SE like you never were up there
when I was with
him no I don't think so I I might I've
seen him on stage but I I don't think I
ever personally met him come the AC DC
thing the tribute I don't think so never
at the store did you watch him live at
the store maybe once no I saw him in
Downtown LA I think it was either
downtown LA or Hollywood for New Year's
Eve one year I saw him it was it's been
he's always been great but to that's
what I could I I don't know if authentic
is the right word that's kind of a weird
word but it just seems like and that's
what you hear a lot from like or I hear
a lot from experienc Comics is you have
to like be yourself and even I sometimes
feel like I don't know like I'm playing
it up a little bit but it it doesn't
feel like always like something I'd say
and what seems like that's stage
time right you don't know it there's no
[__]
uh there's no time limit everybody's
different now I think that you're an
intelligent guy so I'm a [__] you
know Momo Laro I started in
91 and what I
call I really call it this the gift
I saw it one night in
99 in the belly room telling
stories you saw in
yourself for the first time ever I went
up there to tell something and it
changed it up and it came out
beautifully and it was deep inside me
that was coming out and I remember going
home that night going I like that
whatever happened tonight I like that I
got to tap into it a lot more and then
it took a while took like another 30
days to tap into it but I noticed I
would tap into it in front of smaller
crowds okay you know at the store it was
anywhere when I moved to LA like I was
doing a bookstore on uh on Burham
Boulevard I I've always pointed it out
to you it was a brilliant
idea and I would go up there
and do like three sets like what you did
it in LA whatever you just keep doing
sets keep doing sets and
somewhere it'll just come out of you
because everybody wants to do an
audience you know everybody can't wait
to do 25,000 seats well you gotta learn
how to do a 100 and a 300
seater and they're sitting
theart do you follow my biggest lesson
ever was going up
in7 seat room and that being 40 people
listen that that brilliant material you
wrote last night with your buddies at
11:15 at night when there's 28
[__] it might not go over like
you plann g money so what are you gonna
do so now you just go wow I'm eating a
bag of dicks up here and it's the six
minute Mark I still got 11 to go and I
already hit him with my
closer I'm swimming uphill with nothing
I don't even have a hand i'm missing a
[__] hand now so now you just got to
chill
breathe and just start talking to them
about your real [__]
day and that's how it
starts where you go I'm already going
down in flames I already might tell them
about my day and I mean hit him with
everything you got up you took a [__]
you ate Cheerios you don't know why you
really like the Honey Nut but Athena
bought the regular you know
and in that God forbid you leave your
tape recorder on right then you go home
you look at that you go wow what
happened tonight now it takes you
another 30 days to get back there and
that's the levels and that's what you
chase you chase different levels of your
career and the like on top of what he
was saying like I was he he sent some
stuff that like
I would be afraid not I guess the word
is afraid to say on stage like he he
made fun of the venue and it was all
funny but he made fun of the venue he
talked about everybody and like every
like taboo topic
and it made me because it's very funny
that those words coming out of another
comic's mouth would like people would be
booing it but he had 4,000 people like
dying laughing and it's it's very
interesting like the people trust him
now I think
I don't know what it is because it was
all very funny it's not what you say
it's how you say it right study how he
delivers those jokes he turns around he
does the [__] Karen voice he does
this voice you know he tries his hardest
and listen what you seeing up there is
confidence what you're seeing up there
is 30 years what you're seeing up there
is pure Brilliance and figured out how
to put it on the screen when I watch
that movie that's why I like Bill even
more so if you're a young comic right
now I'd be doing what leges did he just
dropped a nickel to go and that nickel
was a [__] investment because first
off let's get this correct you enjoyed
all three of them because I spoke to you
oh yeah after except last night I didn't
talk to you I went to bed [__] nappy
nooo early I was tired I had a long
[__] weekend DG oh I can imagine I
was [__]
tired it's weird i l all of them yeah I
work all [__] week you know I do my
thing I'm a dad I got a drive a
kickboxing you know I enjoy it I I'm
really at a level now where ah I don't
even give a [__] anymore I'm an Uber
driver I'm a [__] I gotta drive to
the thing this week you know it's
tremendous basketball start this week
and is is is your wife coaching again
[__] yeah that's awesome I'm not going
to the practices I'm only going to go to
the
games has your band been
lifted I only had a one game ban that's
it okay gotta bring up the ban and throw
[__] s what that's what you were
saying I thought that's what you were
saying you're not going to the practices
no I'm not going to practices because
you know what I don't want to put
pressure on her I don't want I I can't
can't help I shouldn't even be there I'm
a convicted felony you know what I'm
saying it's not that I don't even have
anything like that but you know I was
talking to a a cop at Jiu-Jitsu okay
told him my situation I go you know it's
so funny how I got in
trouble [__]
27 years
ago I got to do this I got to do that I
got to talk to this guy now they won't
get rid of this warrant but if you got
arrested in California I let you go home
in 10
minutes [__] up let you go home in 10
minutes so that that're holding me
accountable for something that happened
27 years ago when I was a complete
different person and a complete
different world in a complete different
situation and state of mind you know so
I even offered to pay the
fine I don't know I think this is going
to end up [__] going right back to
square
one turn himself in and it looks I'll
never be going to Seattle again I'll
never be eating a nice [__] piece of
salmon again you know what I'm saying
but who gives a [__] I get bigger fish
to
fry that's [__] crazy what kind of
show this week Tarzan talk to me uh this
week last week I did a show at a brewery
and this week I have a show I have two
shows on Saturday night at the silver
tone in Boston and there's a cool little
group out here that has shows all over
every weekend and and they were nice and
I'm I had that last weekend and now I
have this weekend too I'm hosting but
now you're going into the season of
death for young Comics why is that Mike
business because the Boston
Celtics so now you show up for your
little open Mikey at
8:15 but they're like hey Lee we can't
turn off the TV till [__] the game is
over that's happened before now you got
to sit there and drink coffee but they
always hit you with this by the way when
you cut off 10 people you killed the bus
driver you you ran over a bicyclist then
you get there and they're like oh we
forgot to tell you that we can't turn
the TV off until the [__] uh football
is over and then the football game is
off and there's 200 people shooting pool
now you're like what the [__] it's 10:15
these people homeless and now you got to
shoot pool you got to do jokes right
peopleo [__] pool so it never that's
the
skill that you want that when you go out
d i remember doing the longest yard and
one of the gigs they got me was a club
in Chicago like a a SE room okay they
told me to fly in early but I had a show
they paid me good money I'm not
complaining but it was a bowling alley
dog I've done bowling alley no no no no
that's crazy for an open mic or small 50
or a small 20 right it was
like if I would have known I wouldn't
have done it why was it out like where
the bowling was yeah I don't belong in a
bowling alley in [__] Iowa I kept
thinking somebody's gonna hit me one of
those balls and [__] they had like
farmer gear on and stuff I'm in there on
a Thursday night fighting for my life is
that one of the ones we talked about
last week where you just
left I don't know no no I couldn't leave
cuz I didn't have a car how was I going
to get home I'm in [__] petty coat
Junction you know what I'm
saying yeah I couldn't go home so I had
to take eat the bullet in a bowling
alley and guess what they're shooting
[__] bowling
balls no oh yeah I thought you were at
least above it or something oh my God
was a little room that you
know it was in a little room not really
it was in a boundary it was in a
boundary let's call it a boundary with
like a 4 foot thing like a diner you
know a diner in a [__] bone alley
right they cleaned out the tables and
they put like chairs with a make belief
stage and you know it was a [__]
Horror Show Jesus Christ but it prepared
me for what I was doing in
2016 remember I used to tell you that I
used to go on stage at the store and I
would have great sets and while I was up
there at like the minute Mark I do
something and I go oh this is from a uh
something I learned one night at the 8
ball in in Montana you know or this is
what I did one night in Seattle look at
that it came back well this is what I
did one night it really is you start to
see your
path that's a complete different thing
you guys don't need to worry about your
path right now just need to get on stage
eat your [__] Cheerios and do your
jumping jacks got suckers that's it and
get on stage that's it and listen along
the way when you do comedy you're gonna
get beat up listen life right
now is [__] up I get it you understand
me you know things are getting tight
[__] uh I just saw something that
somebody complained they went to uh get
a something at Big Mac it was 16 bucks
for whatever the [__] it is you know
McDonald's is the last Ray of Hope after
you're reading at a
shelter you know no no no no what are we
joking here look what's going on I so
now you know cease fire b boom they're
not stopping they're notop you know and
the united we told Biden to call them
listen the same Biden this is this is
Israel they got into the tunnels now
they're creeping while you're sleeping
they did they got that's what they're
reporting again this is just uh this is
an opinion is something that's going on
right now so work with me my boy is that
it's a little stressful for you people
so do me a favor listen to the s coming
at you better
help hey this episode is brought to you
by better help listen there's your Uncle
Joey here the holidays are coming up
which means your mental health might
take a little nose dive no matter what's
going on talking through your little PRS
and therapy can help you now better
helps online therapy gives you access to
a licensed therapist that you can meet
with over video call phone or even
message it's designed to be super
convenient and work with your own busy
schedule like I've always told you guys
when I first moved I didn't know who to
turn to it was coid nobody wanted to see
people in person I was going through
anxiety I didn't know what was things
were
backfiring and somebody referred
uh betterhelp.com and I got to tell you
something I worked with somebody for
about 9 10 months and here Uncle Joey is
today and let me tell you something you
know me dog I don't like talking about
this stuff but getting started is easy
just fill out a brief questionnaire and
the better help team will match you with
a therapist boom if you don't mesh with
their first pick no problem your swap
therapist at any time at no additional
charge no questions asked so find your
bright spot this season with better help
visit betterhelp.com
Diaz D listen Uncle Joey's giving you
personal do yourself a favor go to
betterhelp.com
Diaz and I'm Gonna Get You 10% off your
first month who's better than Uncle Joey
nobody who's better than betterhelp
nobody that's
betterhelp.com
Diaz betterhelp
hp.com Diaz enjoy the show what's
happened you bad [__] we're
back
anyway what else what kind of plans you
got this week what are you dropping us
well I wanted to there was a fight at in
in the line at the show last night I
forgot to talk about how like it was
crazy like because it made me think of
like it was A8 o'clock show at a casino
on a Sunday like I like surprisingly the
there weren't that many hecklers but it
was like a two older guys
like 45 plus year old guys just started
yelling at and like going at it in the
line it was pretty [__] C have you
ever had I know you had that guy at
Gotham but like and I saw I saw fight at
the at the Chappelle show too that's
crazy hey you see fight the place you're
supposed to go to laugh you're
predetermined to go to the
laugh and now there's a fight I could
see if you're predetermined to go to UFC
right back head you know but it's a
different [__] world now you know so
I get I get all that
[__] so I had let's be honest I started
in the 90s right did all that road
workor I never really saw anything bad I
could lie to the entire you know there
maybe situ I don't know because I would
have remembered
them I didn't anything
bad one time in LA I saw something
hilarious I saw one of the funniest
[__] things at a show in West cina a
club we used to do called The Brave Bull
the guy who ran it God bless him I love
him with all my heart
Rudy and this had to be
9899 we're at the store banging out me
and
Maryland and you know when you work
there before he you went up on stage on
Friday or Saturday would come over to
you and go Joey remember it's a family
room I would go up there and just come
out the gate throwing heat and I would
[__] hit him out of the park and then
I would get off and he go [__] Joey
you know but then and he knew I was
gonna be dirty the next night he come up
to me and tell me the mayor is here I
don't give a [__] okay I'm going off so
now there was a little pause in my
career with Rudy whenever he get mad at
you he gave you like a a six week ban
but listen you went down on a Friday you
could bang
out 65 bucks you went and listen this is
1998 prices they're probably even worse
now so just to let you give you a gauge
you did a a comedy show in a room that
sat like 80 and if you were lucky you
did a room that was 25 people like the
belly room and in that room they had
tacos so you could get up and gra a taco
and they would eat it during your show
and you're up there thinking about your
material you're looking at that clock
and that light because you couldn't wait
for that light to turn [__] red you
get the [__] out of there and run to
that taco table and all of a sudden
there'd be Carnitas or rice and beans
and like some other type of tacos this
place was you have no idea you have no
idea you showed up two year 10 years too
late well one night we show up there
Marilyn's headlining I'm in the little
room and Rudy's not around Rudy had a
gig with Paul Rodriguez somewhere so
somebody else is running the room I get
there the dude pays me I do the little
room that
night okay right if I got off stage in
time I was going to do eight minutes
before Marilyn Martinez God Rest her
soul it was her anniversary of her 16th
year being dead last week the 3D of
November and Rick Ramos's birthday so I
got to give him a shout out and give him
call so I go in there
and Marilyn's on stage already I lost my
guess set but I started set at The
Comedy Store I didn't give a [__] and
next thing you know something happens
with Mar on stage talking to some guy
about a little dick and his wife was
there and she got pissed at Maryland so
she got up and started yelling at
Marilyn some other Mexican tackled the
it was like a heavyweight bra and the
husbands got involved tables were flying
and [__] you know it was a fistic CS you
know I was pissed cuz I was going to
pick up like the small 15 whatever the
[__] I was going to picked up so
jesl got out of there the cops came huh
the cops came oh yeah the cops came the
whole thing they have like a [__] you
ever go into somebody's backyard and
they have like that the wood on top of
wood it's like a little you know that
[__] I don't know what you call them
not shingles but whatever the [__] they
are right they have like little they had
them like make belief stands with
flowers going through them and they had
them all over the back room like left
over from weddings and part-time wakes
like every [__] they have like a combo
taco night Grandpa's dead but he coming
back you know what I'm
saying anyway [__] uh a part-time
wake got me I don't know what a
part-time wake
is nothing anyway when I saw them pull
those things down with the flower and
people hitting each other now listen at
that time it was 99 I was starting to do
not well but I was doing a lot better
than what I was doing in my whole part
of my life right so I just waited for
the cops to come I pulled Marilyn and
her husband out of there I think
somebody else was there what we knew and
the cops were just swarming we were
pulling away
and I never really thought about it
right I went to The Comedy Store did my
spot I you know I probably snorted a
[__] gbo Coke so I must have blacked
out the next morning I got a call from
Marilyn she's
howling wow like what's up DG that was
crazy last night and she goes Joey Joey
Joey she goes my first call this morning
was Rudy and I go what did he say and he
goes Marilyn what
happened what happened chairs were
flying like that was much that was too
[__] much that was just hilarious God
Rest the soul that was I'm happy you
brought that up because I got to tell a
story on her anniversary I feel good now
yeah that's
awesome that's so she was she was going
at and the wife of the guy got up that
upset that they start an entire brawl
guy had a little dick and she said how
do you know you know it really got
[__] like a jealous
thing you know who knows I probably the
only beef I ever had was the microphone
to the head which I'm not telling again
and basically that was really it they we
just drunk people man they go to shows
you know that's I saw something else the
the the thing that always stuck out with
me was I was you're g i I spoke about
this last week how in your career
whatever the [__] you do you can't wait
to get to a certain level as a musician
you can't wait to get to the garden and
then Wembley or everybody has a goal you
know what I'm saying as Comics you got
to be realistic you you're not gonna be
doing comedy going you know what I'm
gonna be open it for Matt r on the world
tour next year you know you gotta be
realistic to yourself so right still
remember getting like uh I forgot what I
was going to tell you that [__]
edible kicking in Jack I I remember
getting like a week somewhere and
getting there oh
[__] did the when I did the
[__] when I did the hosting it was
part of a [__] week in Colorado right
it was Tuesday you had you had Wednesday
off you had Friday Saturday and then
Sunday and Alamosa so Tuesday was CER
Wednesday you had off Thursday was Craig
Friday was Pueblo Saturday something
else and Sunday was Alamosa what the
[__] you laughing about do I'm trying to
talk to you about a schedule here
[__] what are you gonna
do so yeah what oh that just got me see
you had that schedule what schedule yeah
so we had the schedule so that was what
my at the time of being a host that was
my dream right to do that trip
run and that [__] made me do 18
weeks of
hell and I would keep saying to him Dave
what's going on with that
Boulder Dave I want to do a little
homecoming snot some coke at the broker
get a hotel room what's the deal he
would not give it to me and then one day
out of the blue he called and he goes
hey go down this is after I hadn't
worked there anymore he somebody else
was hosting he goes go down there
do a set tonight and if he likes you
I'll put you on the run and he just
called me and then the following week he
didn't put me in Boulder but he put me
in Craig and I remember I was traveling
with somebody and you had to stop and
get a fact machine right like a fact
this is how [__] old I am and then you
read the facts and you gave the feature
Act is fact and I was the feat track
what am I saying here so I'm looking at
this and it says Wednesday where you're
going Thursday Friday Saturday and
Sunday this is why you did that week
because it was a long week and you
worked out
material [__] uh what the [__] was I
talking about here oh
Colorado so here's my first
night it's a sixh hour [__] drive I
pull over at a whatever the [__] Quiznos
whatever Kinkos Kinkos not Quiznos
Kinkos Kinko
I pick up the fact and as I read in the
bottom it says this place is known to
get whatever active if that exit the
stage and go to your room and call 911
well that does me no [__] good you
know that doesn't me no F and I remember
getting there and it was like the uh
thing from The Blues Brothers they had
like 50 feet stage before you and the
thing and they had like a little bit of
a net like just
I remember doing my 30 minutes I gave
him like the light 25 said some stupid
[__] and I went to my room and just
chilled and I never went Colorado they
threw a couple things they really had a
fence in front of
you they had like Shades to deflect
stuff I don't know what they really
called like a it wasn't like the creepy
chandeliers in the 70 where hippies
walked in hey man cool no no no no this
was something different so if not like I
don't know who care who gives a [__] qu
R I just want you to know you're picking
a [__] career of life and danger now
with you get a motel six and the lock
don't work in your room Who you gonna
call ghost
buster you call the room it's an Indian
guy he comes upstairs he don't know
nothing about a lock he tells you to put
the bookcase behind the
door you put the bookcase behind the
door a chair your sneakers your little
Jewish pants and next thing you know
[__] uh you know what did my pants do
the why are my pants Jewish I don't know
I'm just saying Jewish
pants listen you gotta add some humor to
the conversation be so [__] uptight
get what I'm
saying I love it I love doing this [__]
with you oh it's great buddy I love it
too it's great my girls are gone they
come home I watch a little Monday Night
Football I already had dinner I'm Tip
Top M goo I got a light day tomorrow but
she's not no school this week this is a
[__] Hustler like Uncle Joey
no this is the teachers conference and
election day this has been going on
since I came to school here this has
been a whole week right before
Thanksgiving off that's crazy you have
it's two or three weeks before
Thanksgiving right now two is it really
I I don't [__] know what am I a
walking today I'm 60 years old I'm just
worried about today Lis I at next week I
don't know I don't know I might bend
over for a nickel [__] you know next
thing you know I'm walking around with a
moraca
so since I'm a kid Tuesday's election
day tomorrow's election day in New
Jersey and then Wednesday they go back
to [__]
school for a whole day and then you got
Thursday and Friday
off believe it or not we thought about
going away we're still thinking about
taking her out of here I got to stick
around till Thursday so it wouldn't be
till Thursday night because nothing
happens here this week people take off
airport they say is mobed all the plane
tickets out of Jersey and New York go up
this week because everybody goes on
vacation yeah why would you go back for
one day yeah so I don't know what we're
going to do I got to do something
Wednesday I got to do something Thursday
for sure I had to see your beautiful
face you know what I'm
saying that's crazy that's is it like
what what like it's amazing to me she's
going to be 11 soon like it's just crazy
how big she's
getting yes it's
uh I don't know it's making me stronger
watching her grow man it's good I I
picked the right [__] choice and I'll
tell you some other time I picked the
right choice I picked the right path for
right now I'm feeling better you
know what can I tell you sticking to a
[__] schedule for the first time I've
stuck to it for seven [__] weeks
knock on wood so I'm very happy about
that and uh you know I'm still smoking
my dope I ain't [__] perfect even
Jesus drank wine from time to time you
know eat my little mushrooms on the
weekend I don't feel I don't want to I
don't bother nobody nobody knows nothing
no I go to softball games I eat two
pieces of mushrooms and I just stare at
the [__] girls playing softball I
talk to my wife I talk to the other
[__] dads I just watched the girls
throw the [__] you know curve balls
and [__] how they're
learning and it's really nice I've been
watching these girls since they were
[__] seven play together and now
they're knocking on the door of uh you
know pre-teenagers so I'm learning
something every [__] day
as dumb as it sounds you know as [__]
as it sounds that's what we're doing
today who knows what we're going to do
tomorrow I might wake up tomorrow pick
you up and rob a bank in the town there
over there with [__] what what's that
dude's name Ben Ben Affleck yeah we'll
go over there and [__] rob a bank
we'll get caught we'll do parity Federal
they'll put us in a [__] you know
Federal Resort and guess what we'll be
the first podcast via sing sing did you
see that by the way what do you do you
see who has a new podcast who Shug
Knight is it from jail yeah let me
double check here hold on Joe take the
time of that
because I don't know yeah it's it's out
it's called collect collect call was
Suge Knight and they're doing it from
prison how crazy is that that's pretty
intense that that's tremendous that's a
conversation from inside the [__]
jail on a collect call I hope that's you
know it's like a phone call it's like
this only without the [__] Boogie
booie no screen just a blink the phone
rings do you accept the collect call
from Jose Diaz at Hudson County jail yes
I
do and then you get that bill it's
$2,000 every time I [__] call are
they expensive
[__] yeah because they bang you out and
the phone company bangs you out and they
hit you with a search
charge so D it's no party in there
everybody lay everybody gets yum yums
every time you call them your girlfriend
and you're like yeah I'm in here I'm
thinking about you bam that's an $80
bill right there you better get a sock
and stop thinking and get the stepping
[__] Jesus Christ good thing about
hours they had
payones why is that good be like I said
to you if you go listen uh what were
they do you have quarters you can't have
quarters in prison I don't think they
put a phone in prison in prisons till
1973 or something they passed something
you have to don't don't quote me on that
somebody had just mentioned that story
toy so let's say I would have gone to a
higher level facility correct
mhm I would have had to make collect
calls cuz the first four weeks I was in
there all those calls were
collect damn and then and then you went
to a place with my ex-wife my
ex-girlfriend at the
time and she paid my collect calls and
then once I got to Camp George
West it was payones four [__] payones
and how do you pay for it quarters
remember I could tell you we you can
have 40 bucks on you at that place and
then you they gave you money you had
money because you went to the Chinese
restaurant remember I told you you went
to the you go to the B 20 minutes yeah
so they [__] uh I just didn't imagine
like giving prisoners access to a bunch
of change was it like I just I I didn't
think you'd have money I I I didn't
never thought about it like that well
you know what there was a bunch of
people in there bikers there was
Mexicans there was two or three Italians
there was you know but there wasn't no
[__] Asian gang so nobody's gonna
take [__] quarters and flip them into
[__] stars and chase you down at the
[__]
infir the scariest thing where I was was
the barber cut your hair with a straight
racer and when you were getting a
haircut there was a guarden there who
went in there opened the box gave him
the razor he cut like three haircut then
he gave him back the razor the guy put
in the box and walked away he would sit
there like an all like this guy could
have just spped my [__] neck yeah
that's terrifying St Razer it was a
straight razor and then in between
haircuts while he was washing your hair
you put conditioner on there and they
gave him some sort of like Mexican tool
like one of those things from a labomba
movie I don't know I don't know [__]
instruments and [__] they let him
because he was like in there and then he
worked up the level for you to be
allowed to cut air with a razor you have
been a good [__] dude you know you
really turn your life around probably
you didn't get in trouble you didn't get
involved they giving you [__] access
to a razor in
prison or even think
[__] that razor would scare me with
people outside of prison I wouldn't
trust a guy I wouldn't trust would you
go to your Barber and let them use a
straight Razer [__] yeah that's the best
haircut in the world okay I obviously
don't go to the barber anymore so I
don't know I just no you're looking like
doctor you you don't even have a write
off for haircuts no
more you know what I'm saying kill me as
a you you can't even unless you take a
picture with a wig on and send that to
the IRS you know I got this little head
do it cost me
$82.50 a month to keep it up between the
head dye the Muk juice you got to
straighten it out and [__] wa what why
am I dying of tpe wouldn't it already be
the color I wanted it to be what's that
like why am I why is it gonna why I have
to die my
to listen why you asking me questions
that I have nothing you know all I know
right now I'm focusing is who's gonna
[__] I'm thinking about the Jets tonight
they're playing here in Newark whatever
the [__] are are they playing the
Chargers they're playing the charges
it's a three-point [__] game so I'm
just thinking about it you know just for
entertainment to watch the game girls
will be here by the time the game starts
I got go around the corner of my buddy's
house he's got season tickets but he
can't go because he's working today so
I'll go over there with sit with him
with a bag of chips talk to the kid you
know me dog I love all that stuff so
I'll even take Mercy over there with me
because his daughter's there she's
Mercy's a that that's her best friend so
right absolutely CH for a little while I
watched the game of my man and boom
speaking about the game right now let's
take a minute here to talk about one of
my best [__] sponsors a company I
love
DraftKings NBA fans are you guys
watching the NBA right now basketball is
back listen to me you got to watch this
in-house tournament they're having guess
what draftking sports book an official
sports betting part of the NBA has a
crazy offer for you listen they going
nuts over there this is the time of the
year everything's crack a lacking new
customers could call 200 instantly in
bonus bets for throwing down $ five five
American dollars on the NBA that's the
price of a cup of coffee today why not
use that five bucks for something way
more fun $200 instantly in bonus credits
that's a party where why I come from win
or lose it doesn't matter you'll start
the season with an instant dub who who's
better than you nobody basketball is
more fun right now the lines are a
little soft and guess what you're back
in Action download the draftking
Sportsbook app today press code Joey Jo
OE y new customers can get again 200 in
bonus bets instantly for betting the
small $ five all right only at
DraftKings Sportsbook Co Joey where the
crown is yours when was the last time
the crown was yours nowhere download the
draftking Sportsbook app you got a
gambling problem call 800 Gambler all
right or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York call
18778 Hope New York if you got problems
I don't know what to tell you but if you
don't have problems download the
DraftKings app let's wrap this up right
now guys all right so let me ask you a
question since you brought up sh night I
have no Authority on this right to ask
you if you read into it or have a
summary by next Tuesday for the people
because I just I don't know what's going
on I'm scared to look into it like I
don't have time to read one of these
[__]
articles because if it's [__] I'm
gonna get pissed I'm down to minutes
right now I'm not even looking at days
once you hit 60 you got to start
thinking about your minutes
all
right so what do you you want what do
you want a recap
of yeah I want to recap of what's going
on they caught somebody who they said
shot
Tupac and somebody R it it just it was
it was Pete Diddy who put the contract
out on
him you know I I don't know the full
story but you know what's crazy I'm
almost positive Rachel wolfson's death
dad was like the da who got him or
like it was it was a rapper and
apparently he had T I think it was a
rapper I'll look into it for next week
but it was a guy who had talked about it
he in like a documentary or like a TV
show he had talked about like knowing
something and I I don't know if they got
the shooter but they got like I think
this guy was involved if I'm that's like
I pay almost no attention to it but I'm
almost positive I was just moving to La
when that was going down
I
had I had
uh moved I still lived in
Seattle
when Tupac got shot that's when I was
making the move and I lived in La when
the other guy got shot Biggy Smalls both
of them rest in peace and I don't
know you
know I've heard stories about Las Vegas
for years
cameras from buildings satellites you
know cameras at the airport you know
[__] I don't know I've never bought
into it I don't
know but don't ask
really don't ask me who did it I don't
know who [__] did it I have no
idea I tried watching one of those
documentaries and
uh I don't know I I don't believe a
[__] thing so you su's in jail I that
sug Knight had a story to
tell but obviously a
lot that's what I thought I thought by
now he was going to cop to whatever the
[__] time he's doing right now I always
in the back of my mind thought at one
point he would tell a
story I wonder why I it's
crazy I just don't know much about that
world but it just seemed didn't he like
run someone over wasn't that the last
thing that he did on like a film set or
something yeah that's the last thing he
[__]
did it's it's crazy what people do no no
no it's a different [__] world out
there so it's funny that now is when
they caught this dude listen
guys there's people at the end 20 years
later everybody killed Jimmy
Hofer everybody shot this guy everybody
shot that guy at the end you know I
remember one night turning on HBO I know
how old I was I was probably up all
night and it was a documentary about the
ican okay and I remember I was [__]
baffled I was
baffled why it came on again what why
were you baffled because this guy was a
murderer and he lived in an area that I
knew like the back of my hand and at
that time I didn't have access to the
computer and nothing all I knew there
was him and Dr Bowen and Dr Bowen
investigated Crim Dr Bowden I don't know
what his [__] name is I know when
Epstein got strangled that's what they
to do the autopsy so 20 years ago this
guy had his own show on [__] HBO
interesting as [__] Saturday night late
night you went home smoked a number you
made a cheeseburger whatever the [__]
you liked and you watched this show
about him figuring out crimes no this
isn't like secondhand [__] this is the
guy telling you how it went down and one
of those things I put it on one night
and there was the Iceman and the Iceman
told a few stories I was like oh
[__] and then I got lost for a few years
and I saw the second
one the second documentary yes he
probably has two or three of them
maybe and the second one it was kosher
and by that
time I was tra traveling a lot I was a
feat track but I traveled a lot and you
know as true as it may be I [__]
would buy books at all these bookstores
that you see bar and& Noble it was
another place borders yeah B books I
used to always go to borders they had
buy three books get 15% off whatever the
[__] that meant and that's what I would
do one of those places I found the
Iceman book the first first one or
a book where he was
mentioned and then again I went on a
[__] Hiatus and he came back again in
200000 something and by this time he was
arrested he was doing time it was over
and he just started talking about now he
was responsible for everybody but Jesus
Christ he was there when this guy got
shot he was there when this guy got shot
but in that last interview he made a
detail and they made them bring back
Sammy the bull from his slip and two
weeks later he dies in his cell but it
doesn't matter it's crazy that at the
end he was responsible for John F
Kennedy he was responsible for the guy
in the
Bronx because somewhere along the line
he just he was already doing
time why not [__] throw the cops off
and all this [__] he new [__] where
they put uh whatever his name is It's
[__] amazing you start hyping
yourself up you know maybe sell a
bestseller whatever the [__] who
knows that's crazy that someone would
just be like I'm in jail I'm just gonna
C I'm just gonna say murder to everybody
D I knew this was coming like somebody
was gon to do a podcast live from prison
that if if it cost 99 cents to download
he's going to make a [__] shitload of
money
because that's where the podast world is
going next you got to go into a den
where they sell crack and move every two
weeks from then to then oh yeah people
getting shot people doing oxygen hits
you know I I don't know I don't know
what I don't even know there's crack
dens anymore I'm an old man what do I
know I think there might has to be you
got to do your crack
somewhere you know I I don't I have not
seen it around here three years nothing
I go to the city you live a nice place
yeah but even when I go to the city but
I haven't been to the city in maybe two
months and I always go in the daytime I
don't know what happens at night I'm
scared to go to the city at night that's
crazy you grew up there yeah I got no
reason to go over there at night I
really don't I don't blame you so what
kind of Comedy you got coming up this
weekend I'm uh at the silver
tone the end at the end of the month I'm
at the Kansas City improv opening for
Josh and Jacob wolf look at you and [__]
that'll be fun last of the month City
and [__] oh yeah
barbecue yeah I'm really excited I've
never been to Kansas City you know what
man they're nice people listen put it in
the back of your head that they're all
great people oh yeah they work hard for
every [__]
dollar Fridays and Saturdays this is uh
one of their options for
tainment they want to go to some crazy
bar where you ride horses and do dirty
things to it I don't know I don't know
you know what I'm
saying I like I always
liked I'm
sorry it's really weird when you think
about those places when we stopped this
podcast this evening this week's
assignment is for you to look up a
Midwest Booker
a mid comedy Booker check them out do
some research they got them they have to
be right one but people are just lazy
everybody wants to do this there's got
to be people going you know what I do a
Booker in the midwestly books
Ohio you know and now at a young comic a
three to five year comic you're starting
to get the different people in five
years you'll come to me and two years
you'll come to me and go man I'm never
going to that room again they didn't
like me I went to this room in Atlanta o
they [__] booed me and now you build
this thing in your mind so as you're
getting better you're building up more
cities right right but in the time you
ain't going back to those
places for me it was and Charlotte I ate
a bag of dick at a club one night as an
open Miker I went to a showcase for the
club thinking I was Joey bananas and dog
I had a do a set and go right to the car
and get right to the airport that's how
embarrassed I was there was no Co
mingling there was no drink at the bar
like I just ate a bag of dick so I never
went back to Charlotte and then I went
to Atlanta I think with Joe okay died
all weekend at the
punchline died this had to be
90 maybe 2000 it was rough Uncle Joey
and it and you had to work
Sunday oh damn and you didn't do well
any show what's that you didn't do well
any
show I think I had some light one or two
nights but we did like six [__] shows
you know Jesus I never went back to
Atlanta with Charlotte and then there
was a night in Nashville I ate a bag of
dick so I said you know what I'm not
going back to the Bible
Belt it doesn't make any difference and
then when I got to LA
people started offering me gigs in the
Bible Belt and I was like and then I I
got cocky I went back there I'm lying to
you because I think I went back there
98 but this is that whole period yes 98
I thought I was King of the swing and my
buddy got me in with creative
entertainment check them out see if
they're still around okay they're out
North
Carolina and
uh he got me into like a he got me into
a weekend and I died a death of many
dicks then he got me to do a week of one
nighter and I headline with my brother
Vinnie light bulbs we're still great
friends we go back to
1998 in his
truck driving up a hill to I think it
was called Clark Tennessee then we went
to
Knoxville we did like two weeks together
in that [__] truck we did fort lale
we did a bunch of one nighters we
stopped at
places but that whole week dog I
struggled and I had to come up with 45
minutes I had to talk to the
audience some nights I come on too heavy
because Vinnie was
clean Vinnie was very clean so they
enjoyed Vinnie and then I went up there
with a worse accent than Vinnie and they
[__] hate me they look at me like a
Yankee so mental note I ain't coming
back to the Bible Belt
no matter what that's why when they
asked me to go to Nashville I was in
shock because the guy that went to n the
guy that asked me to go to Nashville was
theread or night I ate the bag of dicks
he was in the showroom when I got off
and I remember shaking his hand and he's
like rough tonight what are you gonna do
and I was opening for stanh
Hope wow Stan hope it was 8 o'clock show
the 10 o'clock show was Stephen Seagal
on the guitar you understand me you
serious L you want to come to me with
stories you want to make noise make
noise you know how does steeve Seagal
sound like on the
guitar I think I cried and I ran out of
there back to my hotel I love this two
movies you know he had me with like the
first two movies like all right let it
go after the woman when he came back to
the debt he was paralyzed three days
later he's doing [__] shooting people
and running up and come on you got me
here I don't know much about
paralysis
than [__] three days get [__] life
together and then the Jamaican one was
good I remember getting stuck I was you
know I went to see the Jamaican one
again you played a Jamaican guy nah he
played a cop in the Jamaican
neighborhood okay put voodo on him it
took you for a little while then you're
like Steve that's it I can't do this
anymore and then he went
astray and he went astray he wearing a
wig and [__] and then I bumped into told
by the UFC I didn't say a [__] word
till he turned around and then I talk
[__] kep yelling where's Bobby L being
like 20 where's Bobby L and people
yelling other movies from other little
words from different movies classic oh
my God I didn't say anything until he
turned around did he did he make him
leave or did he stay the whole time
because you probably didn't stop he
didn't he wouldn't even turn around CU
he knew if he turned around get tortured
more after about seven or eight minutes
security got a call and they escorted
him out who shot Bobby
[Laughter]
L that's so funny oh my God I love that
who have you tortured anybody else at a
UFC have I what have you tortured
anybody else at a
UFC couple people but you know I T
everybody everywhere I try you know I
always tell you we got to do a call when
I tell you a story about torturing
people I always I'm always flipping
somebody you know that I'm always
messing with somebody gotta what it
is and you know and like the UFC seems
like the perfect place for you because I
could just see you looking at people
I've been with you when you L see
someone like if he's wearing like an
inflection shirt or like he has sandals
on you're gonna say something you say
something like you'll just sit there the
entire time and have just
comments listen
we already dropped the name you know
what I'm saying so I was at a UFC one
time and I made a guy believe that I
knew him back in the
day because I had heard stories about
the
guy I never met him I went to a couple
of his whatever he did concerts whatever
this Momo did I was a fan in 1990 of of
this guy 91 here I don't know 20 years
later he's at a UFC and he walks right
past
me
so you know I started talking to this
guy and now I heard all the stories
because he came up in Miami so I heard
all the stories so I'm like you don't
remember me and he's like no I don't I
go come on dog I used to play basketball
at your house 1999 man and I started
dropping names he kept at me and he goes
that's right I know you so now I had him
bam and then he kept telling me yeah
when was the last time you I'm 98 I
played basketball every year till 6:00
in the morning the chick showed up now
I'm just talking gibberish I'm just
dropping a [__] story on him he's
like yeah I remember that night that's
right you're a comedian yeah oh [__] and
I'm like I got this Momo then other
people came and they started
torturing and that was the end of that
and what was you just wanted to [__]
with him there wasn't a point to it like
why why did he want him to think you had
grown up with him cuz I got nothing else
going on it's in between fights I gotta
bother somebody
right you gota you know I'm an only
child I love all this type of [__] do
you ever make like your like change your
voice for a phone call like pretend you
have an accent what am I [__] been
toilet qu I only got one voice you know
I remember when I go to voiceovers for a
while come in with an Irish ACC I had to
make a call one
day I got a Puerto Rican accent I got a
New York City accent I got a New Jersey
accent here's the [__] beauty of it
you're listening to all three of
them oh God take tell me what you want
me to say but I'm not gonna come here
and do [__] chip chip Chie ho or
[__]
uh one of those Irish things you know uh
speaking [__] like a leprechaun have
they asked you speak with like more of a
Spanish accent oh yeah and then that
don't work either because they want me
to be Poncho via I show up with this
Puerto Rican cubish you know [__]
[__] it's you it's New York City
wrapped up in [__] three different
nationalities so I'm not going to change
that I don't know you know I look at
these movies
and you see these actors and then five
years later you see an interview and
they're like Australian or English and
you're like what the [__] is
this I saw this guy's a scam you know
this guy's a scam yeah I saw this guy
talking Chinese and all a sudden you go
look him up and he's really English or
Australian the black dude from The Wire
yeah of course whatever um yeah he was
in the office too I'll be office
whatever what office in the
office the guy that was office no the
guy that got shot the guy that uh Denzel
shot yeah strer right no what's his name
I remember goddamn it what the hell is I
know who you're talking about whatever
his [__] name is he played whatever
in the
wire it was great yeah didn't he play
Stringer Bell what the [__] is his name
what happened wasn't his character's
name
Stringer who played Springer hit
me Idris Elba Jesus Christ who do you
think you're dealing with now at one
time he did something at
Carolines he didn't stand
up I don't know I didn't say that he did
I think he was a manager there okay guy
from The Sopranos were both managers
there it's very
interesting but when he speaks he's got
a [__] great English accent you know
but then all Tom Hardy you watch Tom
Hardy in the [__] drop he talks like
I do and then you see him in a jiu-jitsu
tournament and you know you're like what
the [__] is this guy saying I've always
admired that uh the chicken eyes wide
shut that she was a Scientologist for a
while with Tom Cruz but she left him for
the guitar player that movie is [__]
tremendous it's been on lately that is
one of my favorite movies like and tell
you
what for a guy like me it's a disgusting
movie unless if you're doing blow or
you're doing kinky stuff I mean they go
that movie Lee you've never seen this no
this is a two hour [__]
Masterpiece is Scary
Movie No don't do hor [__] Tom Cruz
who's worth every [__] dime they give
this [__] Ducker right and he married to
Nicole Kidman she's like a school
teacher and he's a
doctor and they go to a party and she's
flirting and he's flirting and all a
sudden they get home and they have a
little [__] conversation and Nicole
Kidman does a 10-minute scene that will
make you go what the [__] did I just see
in like a t-shirt with little boobies
that's tight and under and she's her red
hair is up and she's smoking a [__]
joint and while she's telling Tom Cruz
her [__] agonies she's giggling at
him and she's just [__] brilliant but
in that movie she has a [__] New York
accent and then you see her again and
she's got the [__] now you go to the
AMC and there she is hi welcome to this
experience she ain't [__] got no New
York accent that's an Australian chick
so that's my point I got what I got
that's why I couldn't go audition for
[__] mad tv I remember going two of
those auditions where they tell you give
us a
character they barely [__]
room I think I audition for man I
auditioned for some troop in la like a a
one of those TV shows not Frank TV Frank
put me on this is like something from
the WB and I think I went to producers
because I passed the first test that was
brutal
brutal I knew they were gonna throw ball
at me because what do they do they went
from sketches to give us your best
character give us your weakest
character come on you can't drop that on
me on audition I think I play like Lenny
the bookie and
Mar and I walked out of there ripped up
the [__] sides and went to my car and
cried for like an hour because I thought
I was gonna [__] nail this that's a
disappointment but who gives a [__] it's
a learning experience they always going
to throw a curveball at you and look at
the show went nowhere so who gives a
Frenchman's [__] how long did did it
take you to get better at getting over
that
stuff getting over what like
disappointment like something didn't go
well you didn't get the aition you
didn't do well in front of the
booker comedy wise or television
filmwise either one both I I'd be
interested in both as a comic there's
nothing worse than what club and tells
you he doesn't want you there or you're
not his cup of tea meanwhile you're
picking up 20 clubs from a Booker but
the one that bothers you the most is
this guy and he's probably got like two
clubs you really liked them but now he's
telling you had a good weekend you
thought until he Dro [__] bomb on you
and you know what's crazy you try to
keep going back and one day you give up
and five years from then you realize
that when the night after the second
show the waitress you were talking to he
was banging on the side he didn't like
that you were talking to her not even
that you were [__] hitting on a Le
because you would never hit on her but
that's what you find out you go that's
why I didn't go back there because the
wait just came The Green Room and talked
to me and we smoked a half a number with
the other comic so you never know you
can't trip on that and then guess what
one day boom you got a movie you're on a
TV show now they put you out the agency
start putting you out and guess where
your first stop is that club yep and
also that he's at the door how you doing
great to I always knew you were going to
be a star they just listen at that time
they didn't like a lot of Jewish protest
in
town whatever the [__] [__] he would
say to you but now you're selling
tickets right yeah he forgot about that
girl she's not there anymore he's on to
the next waitress and everything is
forgotten just like that and you realize
what comed's all about that if you're
selling tickets they don't give give a
[__] if you light your [__] on fire
as long as people in the chairs and they
drink their two minimum and they get an
order of wings and they get diarrhea and
they get the [__] out of there that just
goes to you it's like anything else in
that in that industry it doesn't [__]
matter you know you could do whatever
you want the bottom line is
[__]
pay-per-views right I went roller
skating and got 3 million pay-per-views
that's great
look at what McGregor's doing and all
the they just released the numbers I
look at those pay-per-views and I go
there's a lot of money out
there yeah somebody's spending a lot of
[__] money out there and whatever God
bless him I'm not you know I love all
that [__] but it's just insane to how
many people worldwide get those things
it's very
enlightening you know so and that's it
brother you've been writing anything or
what
comedy wise no Shakespeare wise yeah
[__] comedy wise yeah you know what I
wanted to ask you a quick question have
you ever said a line in conversation
that just was like you weren't trying to
like it was just something you said that
you turned into a
joke
yes does it usually work like it's it
was crazy like it just happened last
night so I wrote it down I'm excited to
try
it it was just Sunday
afternoon Doug Stan hope had taken me
into his
home he had a girlfriend at the
time and I would
always leave in the mornings I would
take a walk around town apply for
different stupid jobs get a hot dog on
uh there was a little Korean lady down
there that made pretty good fried hot
dogs and I don't know what happened
happened I get back to his house it's a
beautiful day to be alive Wide Awake the
girlfriend's there The Neighbors in
there I don't think Ralphie May's mom
lived next door
yet and I'm in there and I'm a little
fired up you know it's one in the
afternoon I think I got a showcase at
the store I don't know what the
situation was and he's talking about
something and he says something about
[__] you know Doug Stan Hope was raw
that because at that time Doug stanh
hope lived two three blocks away from
where there was like a thing with trans
gender people transvestites whatever
they want to be called transgenders and
that's
fine
so you know something happened and off
the cuff I go Doug what do you give a
[__] about you punch him in the head
when they call the cops and the cops
show up who you going to believe you as
some dude or wig with a black eye a guy
with a wig and a black eye dog it just
came out of
me I remember FH Hope just stopping and
going you're doing that tonight in your
[__] act and I'm like no he's like
you gotta do that joke in your rack if
not I'm taking it make sure you do it
tonight he actually went to the store
and made sure I did it it got an okay
thing and then I just started using on
stage I learned how to use it it took me
maybe a month to figure out how to use
it and years later Rogan was doing it
telling people about that
joke don't same joke that what she gonna
do what are you gonna do when the cops
show up who they gonna believe you is
some dude with a wigging a black
eyy horrible joke but you know what I
had 10 of those you know that you were
in the car with me how many times did we
go for a ride and we die to laughter and
two days later we're talking about it on
stage and it's kind of working and then
we try it again and you were there you
saw the development of this is what we
were talking about in the beginning of
the podcast tapping into that that's
what they want to hear they don't want
to hear the stupidity huh Chrysler went
back to work he I got a job no they
don't want to hear that [__] they want
to hear that
[__] they want to hear that [__] you
tell yourself after you smoke a number
and you're in the
shower and you're in the shower thinking
the most craziest stuff about [__]
you
know and you come out of there and you
like you know what this might rub people
wrong way let me write this down my
journey is to figure out how to deliver
this and for them [__] to understand
what I'm saying may take two weeks it
may take two years like I mentioned
before you might say
something you might giggle your ass off
and one other person might giggle their
ass off but you can't say it you bring
that joke back five six years later when
you have a little bit more confidence
like Bill
bur that confidence he brings up there
and allam the joke works now in front of
[__] 18,000 people I love you
[__] I gotta take two steps to the
rear and get out of here it's Monday
Night Football
I love you buddy it was great to see you
I love you guys and now for a word from
my sponsors have a great week to
[Music]
L what's happening you Savages Uncle
Joey here the checkin is brought to you
by stamps.com they already got Christmas
stuff on the shelves and things are
about to get crazy if you're a business
owner or even just a guy that's got
packages to send then you need
stamps.com stamps.com is your own
personal post office wherever you are
all you need is a printer and a computer
listen I've been with them for close to
10 years my wife still uses them for
little things here and there why because
you print your own post digit discounts
up to 84% off USPS and UPS rates and
stamps.com will even let you know the
cheapest and fastest shipping options to
help you save even more money if you
want to save time as well as money you
can even schedule package pickups and
through stamps.com the dashboard it
couldn't be any easier if I could do it
so can you so do yourself a favor give
yours business the gift of stamps.com so
your mailing and shipping is covered
this holiday season sign up with promo
code Joey for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and Preston Cod Joey